bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
deux auditions de la mission commune
d'information sur la gouvernance
mondiale d'Internet mission commune
d'information notamment consacrée à la
question de la place et de la stratégie
de l'Union européenne en la matière
l'Union européenne qui occupe une place
plutôt restreinte dans ce domaine par
rapport aux États-Unis tout-puissants
cette mission commune d'information
présidée par le sénateur socialiste
Gaetan Gorse et dont la rapporteur et la
sénatrice centriste Catherine main de
sailli a d'ailleurs été créée après
l'affaire Snowden cette affaire qui
montrait que les États-Unis espionnaient
l'ensemble du monde notamment sur
Internet hier les sénateurs de cette
mission d'information ont auditionné
deux anciens ministres de la Culture
d'abord Catherine trotman aujourd'hui
eurodéputé socialiste mais mais
également Jacques Toubon aujourd'hui
délégué de la France pour la fiscalité
des biens et des services culturels tout
de suite donc retour à ces auditions qui
se sont tenues hier au Sénat bien on
peut reprendre ces auditions merci à
Catherine trotman d'être là ch Catherine
député au Parlement européen c'est le
ministre de la Culture et de la
Communication très impliqué dans tous
les sujets qui concernent le net et
c'est à ce titre qu'on souhaitait vous
vous
écouter à la fois peut-être pour faire
le point sur la façon dont le Parlement
européen a abordé les questions révélées
en tout cas suscitées par l'affaire
Snowden mais aussi pour discuter
notamment de la question de la
neutralité du net sur lequel on a
l'occasion de revenir donc dans un
premier temps le plus simple peut-être
qu'on vous laisse quelques minutes pour
faire le point un peu sur la situation
telle qu'elle est perçu aujourd'hui à
l'échelle du Parlement qui s'est
mobilisé sur ces question euh puisqu'il
a réagi en notamment en indiquant que
tant qu'on aaurait pas des garanties sur
la manière dont les États-Unis peuvent
éventuellement utiliser leurs opérateurs
et et leurs fournisseurs et leur euh de
grandes entreprises pour les démarches
de
renseignement validerait pas la démarche
de négociation du traité de de libre
échange c'est une position assez en
pointe donc moi ma première question
mais celle qui pourrait fournir
peut-être un peu de d'entrer en matière
c'està dire comment comment euh évaluer
aujourd'hui la nature de la réaction de
l'Europe est-ce qu'elle est à la hauteur
de la situation qu'on a pu observer
depuis quelques mois est-ce qu'elle l' à
l'échelle gouvernement et qu'est-ce
qu'attend le Parlement européen
aujourd'hui euh d'une discussion engagée
avec les États-Unis ce sujet sachant
qu'on abordera ensuite et notamment avec
Catherine main de sailli notre
rapporteur les autres aspects dont la
neutralité naturellement on pourrait
peut-être commencer par
cela merci je je vais peut-être faire un
peu un petit état des lieux de notre
point de vue euh sur la question de la
de la gouvernance de de l'Internet j'ai
été pendant le mandat précédent c'est
c'estàd de 2004 à
2009 présidente de la délégation du
Parlement européen auprès de la
Commission sur la gouvernance de
l'Internet j'ai donc suivi toute une
série de de réunions depuis depuis le
sommet de Tunis qui a lancé cette
affaire jusqu'à aussi au cours de ce
mandat l'une ou l'autre présence
notamment à Bacou je je n'ai pas été
partout puisque je n'avais plus la la
tâche de conduire notre notre délégation
et je dois dire la position de la
Commission avait quelque peu évolué
entre la commissaire Reding et la
commissaire Cruz et son équipe
donc ce que nous avons relevé dans nos
travaux parlementaires récent et nos
débat c'est un manque d'activité
perceptible un manque d'ambition autour
des questions de de gouvernance de
l'Internet au niveau
européen je pense que ce constat est est
partiellement juste en terme d'impact
mais il faut peut-être modérer ce propos
signaler que l'Union a tout de même
quelques résultats à son actif et que
les institutions nationales ne sont pas
forcément non plus exentes de reproches
parce que ce qui est porté par la
Commission doit être soutenu euh par nos
nos États-membres et j'ai constaté que
ça n'était pas systématiquement aussi
évident euh au fur et à mesure de la
succession des des présidences des
présidences de de de l'Union euh tous
les 6 mois et donc
euh ces questions ont été considérées à
mon sens un peu trop comme techniqu et
par conséquent trop éloigné du du champ
de la parole publique alors s'agissant
des structures et des mécanismes de la
gouvernance à proprement parler au
niveau des institutions européennes
c'est la Commission qui fait le suivi
quotidien de ce dossier ça a été la DG
INFSO avec Madame Reding c'est la DG
Connect aujourd'hui et qui propose les
grandes orientations ça a été la
communication de 2010 que vous
connaissez certainement celle de février
2014 qui est toute récente les
États-membres réunis au sein du conseil
sont quant à eux constitués en groupe de
haut niveau qui le plus souvent prépare
les positions européennes pour garantir
la cohérence au sein du GAC le
le ce comité ce comité consultatif de
l'ICAN et le PE lui est très actif dans
le cadre du forum c'est plutôt notre
espace euh le forum sur la gouvernance
de de l'Internet euh nous avons euh pour
tâche de reprendre et de commenter les
communications de la commission euh à ce
titre nous avons eu un un rapport en en
2010 euh sur les prochaines étapes de la
gouvernance de de l'Internet qui
proposait à la fois une doctrine une
feuille de route et je crois que euh
nous y avions consacré du temps j'ai
personnellement pas mal contribué à
cause de mon expérience et euh nous
avons les uns et les autres apporté nos
nos nos contributions à à notre collègue
rapporteur euh mais par contre personne
ne pouvait anticiper cette onde de choc
global qu'a produit qu'on produit les
les révélations d'edard
Snowden s'agissant de la des agissements
de la
NSE euh le net mondial qui va se tenir
au Brésil va certainement être un moment
extrêmement sensible euh avec l'année
prochaine une conférence internationale
qui va saluer les 10 ans du SMSI de de
Tunis ce que nous avons vécu c'est euh
la comment dire cette
opposition constante entre
uit et Acan et cette querelle de
prérogative sur laquelle je voudrais
dire quelques mots euh on a perçu les
choses comme un peu une guerre de
tranchée qui allait être dépassée qui
était qui était au fond assez passéiste
et que que on pourrait on pourrait
évoluer de manière positive forcé de
constater que ça n'a pas vraiment été le
cas et très clairement depuis quelques
années et avant même le scandale de la
NSE la toile de fond des évolutions de
la gouvernance de l'Internet était
l'opposition entre les adeptes de
l'approche multiacteur ce que nous avons
toujours défendu au Parlement européen
ce qu'on a appelé le multi
stakeholder
approach et nous avons eu euh de ce
point de vue parfois des divergences
mais en même temps euh en général une
convergence sur ce cette méthodes euh
multi-acteur euh et euh ceux qui étaient
les tenants euh d'un
intergouvernementalisme euh qui passait
par les voies euh au fond euh
diplomatiques plus plus classiques la
Chine la Russie l'Iran l'Arabie Saoudite
euh et cetera et donc et en particulier
les émergents Brésil et Inde ont hésité
entre les deux
entre les deux groupes qui étaient
constitués sur des positions
relativement différentes ils se sont
ralliés au premier groupe nous avions
d'ailleurs travaillé par exemple avec
des parlementaires du Brésil dès le
début des Tunis nous avons gardé des
contacts euh plusieurs personnes que
nous avions rencontré ont constitué euh
les équipes qui ont formé un un un un
ministère qui a été dédié au numérique
et donc les les Brésiliens ont été très
allant euh dans la question de la
gouvernance de de l'Internet mais ce
qu'on a constaté c'est que de plus en
plus ces pays émergants avaient des
critique à l'égard des positions de ce
groupe du multipartenariat et cette
tension a connu deux phases on pourrait
qualifier la première de Guard de
tranchée avec des travaux en parallèle
et des échanges qui étaient assez
feutrés voir codés entre les deux bords
c'est la période 2005-2010 la seconde
phase qui a tenu davantage la guerre de
mouvement elle a été marquée par cette
sorte de schisme euh de la conférence
internationale à Dubaï euh et par les
travaux à à l'ONU de la Commission de la
science et de la technologie au service
du du développement là on a euh le
débouché sur une résolution de
l'Assemblée Générale qui a appelé à une
coopération renforcé ce que nous avions
noté dans le forum sur la gouvernance de
l'Internet mais qui au fond était repris
dans un sens euh de contrepoid en
quelque sorte au moutil euh partenariat
qui avait euh cette option plus privée
moins moins gouvernementale que l'option
dite de la coopération renforcé on peut
dire que cette guerre de mouvement
continue avec la déclaration de
montévideéo le lâcher de l'Est des
États-Unis sur l'ICAN et les fonctions
aana et trouve son prolongement dans le
dans ce cette conférence au Brésil du N
mondiale je pense
que ce qu'on peut peut-être constater
c'est
que l'Union européenne a peut-être été
insuffisamment audible peut-être
insuffisamment créative pour éviter au
fond cette opposition alors concernant
Lacan il y a eu un un vrai travail sur
Lacan et je dois dire que que ce soit le
Parlement européen ou la commission il y
a eu énormément de contact avec les
dirigeants successifs de de l'can et
avec ceux qui présidaient Le
Gac il y a évidemment un problème
d'équilibrage entre le bord et les
autres organes consultatifs Le Gac en
particulier
tel qu'il existe le gars qui est une
tentative d'équilibre entre les tenant
d'un rôle privilégié pour les États mais
qui s'inscrit aussi dans ce système
multiacteur privé malheureusement on a
constaté que malgré les efforts les
réformes et les transformations il y
avait un une sorte de double frustration
celle des autres acteurs la société
civile qui est impliquée dans la
gouvernance de
l'Internet qui compte moins dans
l'architecture du coup de Lacan et celle
des États qui voudrait peser davantage
donc finalement ça n'a satisfait
personne et dans cette tension qui a
entouré la mise en place des nouveaux
gTLD le bord c'était au fond assez peu
préoccupé des remarques du GAC nous
avons connu ce pic ce pic de tension le
Parlement européen n'a pas ne s'est pas
prononcer directement mais a rencontré
les responsables de l'can de manière
régulière et a suivi la le lancement des
nouveaux nom domaine générique qui a
donné lieu à à des épisodes douteux
qu'il s'agisse de la Digital
arury qui consistait à cliquer un
instant prédéfini de la façon la plus
précise possible sur le choix des des
des noms de domaines ou comme moyen
accessoire de départager les
propositions de nouveau gTLD et la
définition de l'ordre d'examen on se
souvient du point 20 point wine qui a
été pour nous quand même un peu un peu
sensible en tant que Français en tout
état de cause ce qui nous paraît clair
c'est que Lacan ne va pas pouvoir faire
l'économie d'une sérieuse réforme
interne et même si on a salué le fait
qu'il y avait un effort de de se
redéployer sur des sites nouveaux qu'il
on a salué également cette engagement de
Monsieur chead de de d'arriver à à une
plus grande transparence et à une prise
en compte vraiment beaucoup plus forte
par les groupes consultatifs internes
des attente en matière de de
fonctionnement
euh nous avons tout de même encore un
constat sur la nécessité de réforme plus
structurelle qu'il s'agisse du statut
juridique de l'organisation ce qui est
un sujet qui est posé depuis le départ
ou de la rupture avec Lefin la rupture
du cordonbical qui relie Lacan au
département du Commerce américain c'est
clair que cette question a été posée
depuis le début où il y avait eu une
évolution mais très limitée dans la
conquête d'indépendance de
l'can par rapport au département du
Commerce et le refus des États-Unis de
parler de de tout ce qui concernait euh
les autres sujets qui apparaissaient
comme trop sensibles on peut dire que
les les États-Unis ont bougé la récente
période pourrait laisser penser que les
États-Unis sont sont prêts à une plus
grande ouverture personnellement je ne
suis pas certaine puisque j'ai connu
toutes ces étapes et que j'ai bien vu à
quel point au fond ce pays continuait de
vouloir assurer
euh assurer une certaine forme dite de
garantie mais qu'on peut qualifier
d'influence sur le fonctionnement de de
Lacan sur le forum donc cette affaire
affire n'est évidemment pas pas pas
terminé et au fond la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui s'il n'y a pas de
changement ce serait de considérer que
le choix de Lacan se fait par défaut
mais une gestion par défaut n'est jamais
bonne dans ce contexte sur le forum sur
la gouvernance de l'Internet l'action du
Parlement européen a été assez assez
engagé assez forte même si en fait aux
yeux de l'ONU nous sommes comme
parlementairire membre de la société
civile euh nous n'avions aucune
existence particulière et donc ça
rendait euh la position de la Commission
européenne un peu délicate puisque l'ONU
est une structure d'État euh et nous
nous accompagnonss la Commission et donc
nous étions double doublement en quelque
sorte doublement spécifique à l'époque
le l'ambassadeur mitin desessill avait
nourri l'idée que nous pourrions
sur la base du Parlement européen
constituer une alliance de
parlementaires nationaux et
transnationaux à savoir européens pour
monter en en quelque sorte une un groupe
une compétence parlementaire pourquoi y
avait-il pensé parce qu'il avait
constaté que la présence de
parlementaires européens dans les forums
avait un rôle
plutôt conciliant lorsqu'il y avait des
positions euh confronté et donc cette ce
rôle avait été apprécié et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons toujours
été particulièrement bien accueilli de
la même manière que le Conseil de
l'Europe et son expérience j'avais
proposé à l'époque que nous puissions
sur la base du Forum mondial que nous
puissions constituer le point d'appui
d'un forum européen de
l'Internet qui aurait été au fond situé
euh dans le cadre de l'Union européenne
là je dois avouer que nos institutions
ne nous l'ont pas permis particulier le
fonctionnement du Parlement européen et
la définition de non compéten nous ont
pas permis de prendre cette initiative
de la porter et de la mener à terme
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme nous
travaillons de manière concertée avec le
Conseil de l'Europe le Conseil de
l'Europe a créé un petit secrétariat et
s'est engagé dans euh la démarche que
vous connaissez euh et qu' a mené qu' a
mené de manière assez assez déterminée
euh je crois jusqu'ici avec le rodig qui
est aujourd'hui un peu l'équivalent de
ce qu'on aurait pu espérer mettre en
place il y a eu des débats entre le
Secrétaire Général du Conseil de
l'Europe la commissaire la commissaire
CROUS pour arriver à à trouver un un bon
équilibre dans la participation des deux
euh des deux assemblées euh et je pense
que aujourd'hui ça fonctionne pas mal
mais ça reste quand même très peu doté
et on le voit euh ça supposait aussi que
dans chaque pays membre il puisse y
avoir une sorte de Forum national ce qui
n'a pas été systématiquement créé dans
dans nos États-membres donc on a au fond
aujourd'hui un défaut peut-être je pense
dans la gouvernance de la internet euh
qui est un défaut de prise en compte
législative de toutes les questions qui
peuvent être posées ça c'est pour moi
une vraie préoccupation sachant que les
forums n'ont pas vocation à donner des
instructions ou à exprimer des
conclusions qui
pourrai être avoir un degré de de de euh
disons de de contrainte pour pour pour
une application à transcrire et donc que
au fond euh ce qui nous est apparu c'est
que nous ne devions pas au Parlement
européen mettre en cause la légitimité
du forum de la gouvernance de
l'Internet mais qu'en même temps il
fallait tout en reconnaissant la
l'absence de prise de décision normative
il fallait néanmoins lui redonner un peu
de punch par rapport à la période
présence je trouve que le forum c'est un
petit peu restreint et que nous devrions
davantage le en en faire un terrain un
terrain d'action bon concernant la
France je sais pas si vous voulez que
j'en dise un mot par rapport à la
manière dont je peux le le le percevoir
euh je pense que c'est la première
édition qui s'est tenu le 10
mars a connu quelques critiques je crois
qu'il faut pas il faut pas s'en alarmer
plus que cela ça a été le cas partout
pour moi qui a beaucoup suivi le premier
Forum national qui avait été créé au
Royaume-Uni puisque j'ai une coopération
très très forte et continue avec les
collègues de de de les collègues
parlementairire parlementaire anglais
j'ai pu voir comment il réussissait et
comment il se il se déterminé alors sur
les politiques qui sont impactées par la
gouvernance on a un champ
potentiellement très large c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans mon premier
rapport en 2005 j'avais suggéré la
possibilité de de réfléchir à la mise en
place d'une commission spéciale qui
aurait pu traiter de toutes les
questions qui étaient liées au numérique
mais ceci n'a pas été n'a pas connu je
dirais le l'attention et l'intérêt de
mes collègues bon aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une querelle entre
commissions le lead revient le
leadership revient à la commission
industrie puisque c'est l'approche
technologique qui a toujours prévalu en
matière d'Internet euh mais on a
évidemment des aspects qui sont liés à
la politique industrielle aux questions
de régulation la protection des données
ça c'est la commission Libé les impacts
sur les contenus c'est la commission
culture média et bien sûr tous les
impacts qui sont liés aux droits des
consommateurs lorsqu'il s'agit euh de
servicees ou de la neutralité du Net ou
par exemple du rooming donc euh on a euh
en fait sur toutes ces questions qui
sont aujourd'hui réparti dans plusieurs
commissions et on voit un risque euh de
de de de parcellisation de de l'approche
euh une friction qui euh est de plus en
plus forte euh entre une souveraineté
jridictionnelle territorialisé euh c'est
un débat qui a commencé avec Viviane
Redding et qui n'est pas clos euh entre
les États-Unis et euh l'Union européenne
euh la dimension globale de l'Internet
et des services qui sont sont offert
mais qui peuvent être soumis à des
conditions de service spécifiques euh et
euh les enfin toutes ces questions qui
sont liées au fond à euh la perception
et la définition de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une souveraineté qui resterait
nationale ou distribué entre les
États-membres et l'Union européenne au
moins pour arriver à à trouver au fond
euh le meilleur cadre juridique la
quiiétude qui est la nôtre au Parlement
européen c'est que on l'a vu avec les
États-Unis c'est le risque de voir une
une au fond une extension en quelque
sorte du cadre juridique d'un pays sur
un autre sur un autre pays dans
l'application qui peut-être donnée bon
c'était le cas par exemple pour pour la
l'intervention de la NSE qui prévoyait
de pouvoir écouter des étrangers mais
pas forcément des ressortissants
américains à l'étranger donc ce débat là
pour nous n'est pas clos c'est la raison
pour laquelle dans la la résolution qui
a été présentée par notre collègue
Claude Moraes et qui a été largement
débattu nous avons voulu poser ces
principes très clairs de protection des
données personnelles et de respect des
droits et libertés fondamentales en
réalité les Américains ont commencé à
s'en pré occupé euh précisément à
l'occasion de discussion sur euh
l'accord
Swift sur le second accord
ACTA mais à la suite de rencontr qui
avait eu lieu dans le cadre du du forum
sur la gouvernance de l'Internet puisque
le président américain Obama avait
envoyé son collaborateur chargé des des
droits des droits fondamentaux et il
avait observer les positions qui étaient
cell des parlementaires on a eu la
possibilité d'en d'en discuter et la
question qui nous avait été posé aussi
bien par le département du Commerce
américain que par ce conseiller de
d'Obama lui-même c'était est-ce que les
Européens vont
intégrer les droits fondamentaux dans
les accords commerciaux est-ce que ce
sera désormais une
condition et il faut dire que dans C
question il y a bien sûr cet aspect qui
concerne en particulier quelques
entreprises qui ont une emprise
phénoménale sur internet je pense à
Google je pense à Apple et bien d'autres
euh mais il y a en même temps aussi le
cadre dans lequel on peut continuer
d'avancer il me semble que les les
États-Unis sont inquiets de pouvoir
garder leur rôle en même temps de plus
en plus conscient que euh il peut peut
exister y compris chez eux un mouvement
de citoyens qui exige la
transparence la possibilité de de
d'exiger les mêmes conditions de droit
que les Européens du moins c'est ce que
j'ai entendu de la part de plusieurs
mouvements de citoyens aux États-Unis et
il est clair qu'il y a aujourd'hui sur
le plan international sur le plan
mondial une
sensibilité très forte à la position
européenne puisque c'est celle qui est
la plus complète euh et qui a posé de
manière plus précise le cadre juridique
dans lequel pouvaient être défendus ses
droits et ses libertés et donc je pense
que c'est un des éléments qui s'était
imposés dans le cadre de la gouvernance
de l'Internet de fait parce qu'il y
avait censure dans certains pays et même
censure au moment du sommet de Tunis
puisque euh le gouvernement de l'époque
euh avait censuré même des chefs d'État
euh dans leur intervention et donc euh
et nous avions choisi avec la Commission
européenne le Parlement européen de
tenir un atelier un workshop sur euh la
censure et le respect des droits
fondamentaux ce qui avait été un moment
de très très grande tension ça le reste
avec un certain nombre d'interlocuteurs
que vous vous imaginez bien euh pour
pour la suite donc voilà o où nous en
sommes euh sur la neutralité on vote
cette semaine dans le cadre du règlement
euh qui est en cours de débat sur la
protection il y a cette directive un
règlement mais on aura une une
discussion quand même assez ardue après
notre vote avec le le Conseil puisque on
a une position différente du Royaume-Uni
qui est plus qui est moins moins avancé
disons que que celle de certains autres
pays euh sur la régulation exanté euh on
a depuis la fin des années 90 un cadre
juridique évolutif des directives
cadrees
autorisation accès pour ce qui concerne
les les Télécom nous aurons à procéder à
une révision dans la prochaine
législature et je l'espère ce nous
devrions revenir à un terrain plus
équitable notamment entre opérateur et
et Gafa puisqueaujourd'hui il y a un
véritable déséquilibre donc ça c'est un
des enjeux de la prochaine période sur
la politique industrielle je pense qu'on
peut dire chez le point de vue de notre
Parlement que l'Union européenne a perdu
beaucoup de terrain euh qu'il s'agisse
de notre capacité manufacturière mais
aussi de notre influence sur la
politique des normes et c'est évidemment
un
moment inopportun de pour nous de perdre
cette influence sur les sur les normes
et comme vous le savez il y a ce groupe
de haut niveau sur la fiscalité qui a
été mis en place
donc ce que je peux dire en conclusion
c'est que nous avons aujourd'hui une
réponse qui est relativement euh nous
avons plusieurs types de réponses elles
sont relativement éparses nous avons des
manques pour arriver à à consolider je
dirais une des instruments suffisamment
solides il n'y a pas eu de révision
effective de la directive service
universel qui aurait pu permettre de
définir
positivement les conditions d'accès par
exemple à Internet ce qui aurait été
utile y compris dans les débats qui
concernent je dirais tout le
fonctionnement de du
système et d'autre part nous n'avons pas
non plus revu la directive commerce
électronique ce qui devrait être fait
puisque nous avons aujourd'hui des
distorsions dans l'interprétation et et
dans les entre les directives et et les
règlements donc je dirais il faut que
dans la prochaine législature nous
procédions à une
révision méthodologiquement
complète
sû que nous répondions à toutes les
questions que nous replacions l'ensemble
des
sujet dans une cohérence
intrinsèque ce qui serait une façon de
donner un instrument à la Commission
européenne et aux États-membres pour
pouvoir agir de manière plus efficace
sur les questions qui sont liées à la
gouvernance de de
l'Internet merci beaucoup
Catherine très bien je reste sur la
conclusion que vous avez formulé parce
que c'était une des préconisations du
rapport que que nous avions fait au nom
de notre commission des des affaires
européennes donc on constate c'est
heureux pour le Sénat qu'on se rejoint
sur le sur le diagnostic j'aurais
quelques question complémentaire euh
vous avez évoqué la la résolution
européenne qui vient
d'être adopté euh qui entendait adresser
donc une demande formelle au Conseil
européen pour intégrer un Abas corpus
numérique qui protège donc nos droits
fondamentaux està dire que notre Charte
européenne des droits fondamentaux ne
serait pas aujourd'hui un texte
suffisant pour pouvoir garantir cette
cette protection de de ces droit à l'air
numérique en fait ce que nous avons ce
que nous avons vécu déjà dans précédent
débat euh c'est qu'on av fait des
problèmes de de définition
euh et d'ailleurs on a eu on a eu des
des échanges et des discussions assez
abondantes euh puisque au fond les
Européens écrivent euh écrivent le droit
euh le Conseil de l'Europe l'a l'a fait
bon il y a eu des propositions de Bill
of Rights euh qui était au fond des
chartes des droits numériques c'est un
peu on se casse un peu les dents hein
sur l'écriture d'une de charte de ce de
ce type mais c'était extrêmement
important il faut passer à un exercice
d'écriture et de et de de vérification
pourquoi parce que lorsque nous avons eu
le débat lors de la révision précédente
du Paquet Télécom euh la concomitance de
l'adoption en France de la loi adopie
avait provoqué beaucoup de remous dans
nos propres débats et euh la France
avait voulu à l'époque de la présidence
française euh en quelque sorte
sanctionner positivement une loi qui n
nétait pas en débat euh sous l'angle
d'un texte européen soumis à notre
Parlement on était dans une révision
d'un paquet euh législatif qui
concerernit les les télécommunications
et non pas euh le téléchargement mais
les choses vous souvenez se sont
emballés sur l'amendement 138 et euh la
question était euh de pouvoir
euh procéder à des sanctions euh après
euh un une procédure préalable préalable
était le mot qui a provoqué le report
sur la la législature suivante début
2009 de l'ensemble de ce paquet puisque
certains le refusaient d'autres le
voulaient et il a fallu aboutir
entre-temps ce que nous avons pu faire
c'est intégrer la référence à ce texte
c'est-à-dire un texte qui concernait au
fond des techniques euh et un
fonctionnement un fonctionnement euh
administratif technologique juridique
euh du secteur des télécommunications
nous y avons intégré euh une première
définition de la neutralité du Net euh
notamment en affirmant la liberté de
choix de l'utilisateur final mais en
même temps la référence à la charte des
à la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme euh nous l'avons nous l'avons
fait pour euh parvenir à
euh une prise en compte le plus en amont
possible de la Charte des droits
fondamentaux de la Convention
plutôt que de dire que internet était un
droit fondamental ce que certains
disaient c'est un être connecté est un
droit et on peut le qualifier de quasi
droit
fondamental mais une technique ou une
technologie ne peut pas être comparé à
un droit donc il fallait clarifier les
choses donc c'est plus je dirais la la
l'expression de l'application des droits
fondamentaux au secteur du numérique qui
doit être intégré en référence dans nos
textes aujourd'hui ce qui nous anime
dans la période
présente par rapport à la protection des
données personnelles ça c'est directive
et règlements nous avons eu des
approches
différentes en
particulier sur le degré de de de
protection et sur la liberté d'usage sur
le la possibilité de transférer les
données c'est toute la problématique du
cloud qui a été fortement traité aussi
dans la gouvernance de de l'Internet et
donc il est clair que nous ne pouvons
pas simplement considérer que les la
formulation des droits fondamentaux
d'aujourd'hui suffise à définir les
droits que nous voulons défendre dans le
cadre d'internet c'est la raison pour
laquelle on y procède mais qu'on a un
peu de mal parce que c'est dur de
légiférer
euh dans ce domaine-là et donc nous nous
avons un débat dans la période sur la
définition de la neutralité du Net
euh sur la gestion du
trafic sur ce qu'on peut appeler un
Internet ouvert qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un internet ouvert open Internet et
comment définir les services spécialisés
je ne dis pas que à l'issue de la
première lecture du paquet CROUS actuel
euh on aura résolu tous les problèmes
parce que plus on creuse plus on se rend
compte que c'est difficile mais si on
veut réformer correctement le droit des
contrats euh et avoir une application
correcte euh par les
régulateurs on est obligé évidemment de
de d'avancer on peut pas uniquement
définir
euh tout définir par la négative il faut
qu'on puisse aussi écrire positivement
euh ce que nous voulons euh
proposé comme
garantie sur les libertés sur
l'accès sur la liberté de choix sur la
protection des données
personnelles je vous remercie peut-être
avant vous puissiez nous exposer quelle
est votre vision de la la neutralité du
Net parce que je crois savoir vous
travailleer intensément sur sur ces
sujets
également pour rebondir sur la
protection des données personnelles que
vous venez évoqué à travers le projet de
de règlement intérieur pourriez-vous
nous donner votre point de vue votre
appréciation des divergences des points
de divergence entre le le le le Conseil
et le Parlement qui qui freine
l'adoption du texte vous avez évoqué un
travail aussi que vous menez avec nos
homologues britanniques nous avons eu
l'opportunité de rencontrer no nos
homologues allemands mais un autre point
de vue nous semble utile semble util de
connaître un autre point de vue pour
éclairer aussi notre compréhension du du
suet quel est le jeu aussi du du
lobbying venant d'outreatlanti qui
freine l'adoption de ce règlement on
aurait pu penser que au lendemain de
laaffaire snodon au contraire il y
aurait eu une volonté d'accélérer
l'adoption du du
règlement bon en fait la tel que nous
avons perçu les les choses si vous
voulez aujourd'hui on a dans dans tout
ce secteur et entre nos états si on
prend le sujet à
partir de la situation des
télécommunications on a on a une
évidemment une disparité très très forte
entre les les États-Unis et l'Europe
d'un côté on a une centaine d'opérateurs
de l'autre côté on en a quatre euh une
situation de concurrence en
particulier dans tous les service mobile
qui est qui est réel mais en même temps
aussi des freins avec nos nos marchés
nationaux que nos
opérateurs défendent de mordicus pour
garder une base économique suffisante
donc on a aujourd'hui une une tension
sur ce marché sur le développement des
services et depuis la révision
précédente du paquet on a eu une
pression pour que soit possible les
services transnationaux nous avions
demandé à la Commission
européenne de définir et de mettre en
place si vous voulez des services pan
européens la définition des services pan
européens de manière à ce que ça soit
pas simplement une facilité
technologique qui permette d'offrir un
même service dans tous les pays de
l'Union européenne ce qui est en soit
que je ne condamne pas du tout mais qui
peut évidemment
avantager certains
opérateurs qui qui viennent avec des
moyens beaucoup plus importants que nos
propres entreprise européennes donc ça
ça a été un aspect que nous avons que
nous avons discuté
et ça a été souvent un point d'entrée en
disant bon vous avez au fond un une
sorte de désavantag économique en Europe
parce que vous avez un marché
fractionné nous voulons un
marché un marché le plus harmonisé
possible mais avec toutes les facilités
d'accès
technologique commercial juridique très
bien ça c'est un premier point virgule
nous voulons avoir accès aux
données éidment si on calcule la valeur
des données
personnelles comprend très bien ce que
ça veut dire et donc la la tension entre
le groupe PPE et notre groupe socialiste
et démocrate a porté
sur C ces deux approches de la même
manière sur la neutralité du net
aujourd'hui on a une approche plus
business friendly si je peux le dire en
anglais du côté du PPE et plus euh
citizen friendly euh du côté des
socialistes et démocrates des libéraux
des veres et de la Goué donc euh on
s'est clairement diviser euh sur euh la
vision euh sur l'approche euh des
développements euh en matière d'Internet
entre ceux qui considèrent euh qu'il
faut le moins réguler et le moins
administré et donc introduire le moins
possible de définitions qui pourrait
avoir un caractère général et
public et ceux qui considèrent que si on
parle d'accès à Internet pour tous il
faut bien parler d'intérêt public ou
d'espace public ou de quasi service
public comme l'a défini le Conseil de
l'Europe donc on est si vous voulez sur
on retrouve
d'ailleurs peut-être de manière
différente et là font
renverser le débat que j'aiévoqué à
propos de l'can et de l'approche
iu une approche plus proche des états et
une approche plus proche des opérateurs
et des acteurs
privés là en l'occurrence pour nous au
Parlement on a plutôt une approche
multiartenariale mais avec un cadre et
c'est c'est là-dessus que nous avons
cette différence et où évidemment on a
constaté une moi je fais partie de la
fondation européenne de l'Internet fait
partie du board et donc nous avons des
réunions régulières mais où sont
présents des entreprises de différents
horizons hein il y a pas que des
entreprises américaines il y a aussi des
entreprises européenne mais comme je
l'ai remarqué dans ce cadre là ou dans
le cadre
du forum sur la gouvernance de
l'Internet nos entreprises européennes
ne sont pas assez
présentes on les entend pas assez pas
assez organisé pas assez présente pas
assez je
dirais active plutôt sur la défensive
quand d'autres google et autres sont
beaucoup plus à à
l'offensive sur sur la la la question et
donc au fond ceux qui nous ont
le débat porté sur une un reproche voire
une
accusation de vouloir encadrer
internet ceux qui voulaient garantir le
plus la neutralité les libertés étaient
ceux qui au fond voulaient empêcher
l'innovation et le déploiement le
déploiement de de nouvelles possibilités
activités services et là pense qu'on est
dans la caricature on est je pense qu'on
est sincèrement dans la caricature et
j'ai trouvé que que à propos de du
rapport enfin des différents textes sur
la protection des
données le les pressions était
excessives je l'ai j'ai pu le le dire
personnellement à certains opérateurs en
leur disant que euh un excès de lobbying
nuisait beaucoup à la cause qu'il
pouvait défendre et quand qu' en Europe
on ne réagissait pas de la même manière
on n'est pas forcément complètement
impressionné quand on nous dit que le
modèle d'un Internet libre est
automatiquement libéral et totalement
libéral et sans sans
contrainte et donc voilà c'est c'est ça
qui a été le le cœur du le cœur du débat
mais la
question alors forcément la NSE a a a
provoqué une prise de conscience chez
les collègues parce que on était en
train de discuter sur la
cybersécurité et donc de tous les toutes
les questions qui pouvaient être
liées aux questions de défense de risque
de criminalité et cetera et en même
temps sur les textes qui relevé de la
protection des données donc on a pensé
que ou bien ça passa ou bien ça passait
pas parce que ça devenait politiquement
hyp sensible
voilà aujourd'hui les différents les
différentes parties prenantes sont
beaucoup plus
prudents le vote je dois ajouter que le
vote que nous avons
exprimé sur l'exception
culturelle dans le mandat de la
commission sur le traité transatlantique
sur le traité de partenariat
transatlantique le ttip a été très mal
accueilli par nos interlocuteurs
américains et très reproché à la
France très reproché à la France c'est
une autre des conditions et comme vous
pouvez le
constater il y a un lien entre les deux
c'est-à-dire que lorsque nous avons
débattu de l'exception culturelle on l'a
prise tel qu'elle était c'est-à-dire
l'exception culturelle libéralisation
des services audiovisuels bon là avec
une extension mais pas l'ensemble de ce
qu'on de ce qui relève de la culture à
proprement
parler mais les éléments de débat ont
très vite débouché sur au fond avec les
directives que nous avons sur la
télévision
euh sur la télévision enfin les
les tous les états précédents de de nos
travaux nous ont amené à considérer que
on avait quand même un droit de regard
sur la manière dont on traitait les
contenus les contenus
culturels et à partir de là qui dit
contenu qui dit diversité culturelle et
linguistique dit en même temps droit de
chacun à disposer convention d'UNESCO de
sa langue et de son héritage culturel
et le le scandale de la NSE a fait
prendre conscience qu'entre ce qui était
le choix d'accès au service que l'on
souhaite à un Internet ouvert qui
n'était pas contraignant sur les
contenu poser autrement la même question
que celle que nous avions posé sur
l'exception
culturelle et dans mon groupe par
exemple le vote a été
emporté sur ces deux points c'est que il
y a trois il y a trois facteurs qui
compent un le risque concernant
l'exercice des libertés personnelles de
ce qui a trait à la à la à la à la enfin
au données aux données
privées mettons tout ça dans le même
paquet de les contenus 3 le risque de
d'espionnage d'espionnage
économique que les Allemands par exemple
ont fortement soulevé par rapport à la
possibilité au moment du débat sur sur
Swift donc notre Parlement a connecté
l'ensemble de ces
débats nous avons voté non sur
swist nous avons voté non sur le traité
ACTA c'est là que nos amis américains
sont rendus compte qu'on existait que le
Congrès américain s'est dit bon s
Parlement européen à la possibilité de
dire non à un accord
international oui euh on va pas mal
l'utiliser mais on a dit à quellees
condition allait l'utiliser donc on a un
double cliquet aujourd'hui qui est très
important par rapport à notre
conception et ce double cliquet a été
particulièrement
observé par nos interlocuteurs et pas
seulement américain par les Chinois
aussi parce qu'à partir du moment où
parallèlement nous mettons dans les
conditions qui portent sur les accords
commerciaux Inter internationaux des
clauses
sur les ce qu'on appelle nos clauses de
sauvegarde environnemental et sociale
mais que ces clauses portent aussi sur
des aspects culturels ou de liberté de
droits
fondamentaux là on tient une position
qui est une position
évidemment forte forte et particulière
donc je pense que la la la position de
la France face à ces questions est une
position très trs euh très importante on
a vu que la France était beaucoup plus
alante dans les conditions du
ttip à la fois sur l'origine
géographique et sur d'autres sujets qui
n'ont pas trait à Internet mais les
conditions qui étit posé sur l'exception
culturelle ont immédiatement été entendu
par nos interlocuteurs comme une remise
en cause de des entreprises des géants
enfin des géants du Net et euh et donc
une une attitude offensive euh par
rapport à par rapport à la protection
des
données j'avais une toute dernière
question sur euh donc le le
cfarba qu'est-ce qui pourrait remplacer
aujourd'hui le le sefe Harb pour
garantir justement euh la protection des
des données des des étrangers qui
peuvent être aujourd'hui transférés
qu'est-ce qui pourrait euh remplacer le
C le SAF pour garantir de manière
effective la protection des des données
personnelles des Européens qui sont
transférés bon ce que nous nous sommes
employés à à définir c'est plus euh
cette référence au
C et aux conditions dans lesquelles ça
pouvait
fonctionner est-ce que vous est-ce que
je peux vous renvoyer la question est-ce
que est-ce que nous n'avons pas été
assez pr précis dans dans les textes que
nous avons établis euh pour pour dans
votre lecture ou ou est-ce que est-ce
que vous attendiez plus du Parlement
européen ou ou ou est-ce que je
comprends mal votre question ou on
aurait voulu être éclairer davantage en
tout cas entendre de votre bouche votre
point de vue sur sur la question comment
remettre de de de l'équilibre
entre en fait les Américains et nous sur
ces sur ces questions
alors moi je pense que si vous voulez au
point où on en est
aujourd'hui je crois que nous sommes
allés le plus loin possible du côté du
Parlement européen que nous pouvions
parce que bon je vous l'ai dit nous
avons des différences d'approche entre
entre groupes donc on est allé on est
allé très très loin en ce qui concerne
le Camba et la et la
protection nous avons certain nombre de
points qui ne sont pas
complètement
finalisés c'est la question du
transfert et la stratégie et là nous
sommes à peu près autant divisés que nos
États-membres entre ceux qui considèrent
qu'il faut il faut une sorte de de
de de constitution de notre espace et de
nos moyens numériques européens et ceux
qui considèrent que ce n'est pas
nécessaire et donc
alors je pense qu'on a dépassé ce qui a
été évoqué au début par exemple avec
l'exemple de Los Angeles qui avait pris
une décision en disant toutes les
données qui concernent ma population je
veux pouvoir les gérer et assurer que
elle reste dans l'air géographique de la
commune bon je pense qu'on peut pas
raisonner comme ça la question se pose
réellement à l'échelle européenne et je
crois que
euh dans la la la progression de la
réflexion à ce sujet on on serait assez
tenté me
semble-t-il de défendre de défendre la
position qui permettrait à l'Europe de
prendre une initiative dans ce domaine
pour pouvoir garantir
effectivement la sécurité et la
protection des des données des des
ressortissants européens écoutez je vous
je remercie beaucoup
pour vos propos extrêmement complets euh
nous sommes très heureux de
pouvoir auditionner une députée
européenne de de renonce dans nos
travaux depuis quelques mois en tout cas
ceux qui ont débuté la Commission
européenne justement ce qui nous a un
petit peu manqué c'est peut-être un peu
plus de de de de contact avec nos nos
hologues européens mais c'est à nous
aussi parlements nationaux de de faire
bien sûr la la démarche et des contacts
aussi avec les députés européens des des
étatm parce que on on veut un petit peu
sentir quelle est aussi leur
appréciation des des des des les sujets
si on partage le même diagnostic et on
se pose les mêmes questions avec
forcément les mêmes préoccupations en
tout cas merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
en tout cas moi j'ai lu avec évidemment
beaucoup d'intérêt et je me réjouis euh
de voir le résultat de ces auditions
parce que je pense que c'est extrêmement
précieux aussi pour nous et si vous le
souhaitez nous aurons certainement dans
la prochaine période euh à connaître des
étapes de travail sur la la révision euh
de nos textes je proposerais que
vous-même votre collègue euh puisse
également être entendu
par par les les les les groupes qui
travailleront parce que nous ne sommes
pas si nombreux euh à suivre ces
questions et ça c'est un c'est un vrai
problème euh que nous avons c'est un
problème de culture et là nous sommes un
petit groupe de députés européens qui
suivons le sujet depuis un certain temps
euh et qui donc connaissons les limites
dans lesquelles nous travaillons mais
aussi les les enjeux stratégiques
nous allons établir nos priorités pour
la prochaine commission n'hésitez pas à
nous dire ce que vous considérez comme
important parce qu'on peut aussi se
faire l'écho de ce qu'attendent nos
États-membres bien entendu et donc moi
je vais travailler là-dessus avec mes
collègues et je vous invite à du coup àf
on utilisera vos vos travaux intensément
pour le CAH descharges de la prochaine
commission vous avez je crois qu'on a
tout à gagner à travailler entre députés
nationaux et députés européens sur
l'ensemble des sujets d'ailleurs mais
peut-être sur celui-ci encore plus
particulier parce qu'il ément
stratégique et que nous sommes trop peu
comme vous l'avez évoqué c'est la même
chose au Parlement français et au Sénat
à travailler sur ces sujets mais cette
mission d'information qui est regroupe
33 parlementaires a justement pour viser
de d'entraîner l'ensemble des collègues
sur ces sujets qui sont incontournables
voilà en tout cas merci
infiniment
bien monsieur le le ministre tout
d'abord je je voulais vous souhaiter la
bienvenue au Sénat alors vous connaissez
l'objet de notre mission commune
d'information qui est de au-elà du du
rapport que la commission des affaires
européennes du Sénat avait réalisé sur
la gouvernance européenne des numériques
qui est de réfléchir
aujourd'hui aux nouveaux enjeux à la
nouvelle stratégie qui conviendrait pour
l'Europe d'adopter dans le cadre d'une
réflexion euh sur la gouvernance
mondiale de l'Internet et ce d'ailleurs
à la veille de la euh due n mondial qui
va se tenir ce mois-ci à à à à Sao Polo
euh forcément notre mission est plus
particulièrement intéressée de vous
interroger sur les question fiscale
puisque c'est la la mission euh qui vous
a été confiée par le le président de de
de la République aussi sur les sujets
qui qui qui nous concern est-ce que vous
pourriez d'abord peut-être avant qu'on
revienne sur des questions euh euh nous
nous confier votre point de vue sur
cette question qui voilà nous préoccupe
tous autant que nous sommes par avance
merci je je je remercie encore une fois
le Sénat et vous en particulier
de de prêter attention à mes opinions
donc je vais essayer de m'exprimer une
nouvelle fois sur ces sujets dont nous
avons
nous sommes souvent
entretenus je pense que s'agissant du
sujet que vous avez mis à l'ordre du
jour de votre de votre mission
d'information
euh il faut traiter de manière distincte
deux questions en essayant de donner au
mot leur vrai sens étant entendu en plus
que ils n'ont pas tout à fait le même
sens lorsqu'on parle anglais ou
lorsqu'on parle français c'est donc je
je m'explique je crois qu'il y a deux
choses que je vais traiter
successivement dans ce petit propos
introductif la gouvernance et la
régulation étant entendu que en anglais
la régulation ce n'est rien d'autre que
la réglementation ce que nous appelons
nous la réglementation alors que nous
européens et français en particulier
nous donnons au sens régulation un un un
sens que nous prétendons être
anglo-saxon mais qui en fait n'est pas
celui que bon mais sur la je vais alors
parler de la gouver ensuite de la
régulation la gouvernance de l'Internet
en fait c'est une question de technique
et c'est une question de technique de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce
quelles sont les mesures techniques qui
sont prises pour que le réseau
fonctionne à travers le monde et il se
trouve de fait que ces mesures
techniques sont toutes d'une manière ou
d'une autre directement ou indirectement
de fait sous entre les mains
d'entreprises privées ou
d'administration américaine et que ce
sont des mesures que je qualifierai de
fait c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour que ça marche et
qui n'ont pas fait l'objet
d'accord internationaux d'accords
diplomatiques de règlements négociés et
qui se sont simplement imposés au fil du
temps et depuis que l'Internet il y a un
minaine d'années ou 25 ans et et est
àenu et qui se traduit par le pouvoir de
l'can mais le pouvoir de
l'can c'est un pouvoir de fait vous avez
très justement évoqué vous avez très
justement
évoqué la prochaine session de l'
au Brésil je voudrais évoquer aussi un
autre événement c'est que c'est
aujourd'hui l'an est désormais présidé
par un président égyptien et
que on peut imaginer on peut imaginer
monsieur chadet on peut imaginer
que la présidence
égyptienne et je l'espère
le les position
européennne permettront au moment
où il y a beaucoup d'interrogations sur
la gouvernance de l'Internet y compris
aux États-Unis permettront de passer en
quelque sorte de cette
situation de mesures technique
à une situation où de manière négociée
et don donc naturellement plus équilibré
qu'aujourd'hui il serait tenu compte des
positions et des intérêts de tous à
travers un
accord international et moi je pense que
l'Union européenne devrait à sa Polo
plaider pour que la gouvernance mondiale
de l'Internet soit à tout le moins
l'objet d'un certain nombre de principes
écrits
euh négociés et pas seulement encore une
fois euh le pouvoir de fait euh d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises et d'un
certain nombre d'administration
américaines qui travaille avec ses
entreprises ça c'est le premier c'est le
premier point mais il est clair que sur
un certain nombre de sujets et notamment
la prise en considération des données je
dis pas la protection des données mais
la prise en considération des données
comme matériel fondamental de de de de
de de de l'Internet
euh du de l'économie de de l'Internet
euh nous pourrions à travers de tes
négociations naturellement faire valoir
notre point de vue et ceci d'ailleurs
rejoint je crois euh les positions d'un
certain nombre de de d'administration ou
de ou de ou de de de
de d'expert américains qui se pose
justement la question de savoir comment
prendre en compte aujourd'hui les
données dans la gouvernance de de de
l'Internet ça c'est donc la gouvernance
au niveau mondial et je crois que
l'Union européenne devrait essayer dans
toute la mesure du possible d'avoir une
position qui serait d'imposer la
négociation d'un
accord la deuxème question c'est la
question de la régulation c'est celle
que nous
avons déjà abondamment et que vous avez
vous le Sénat aussi abondamment traité
euh et qui concerne l'Union européenne
proprement dite
euh ce sous le le le chapeau de de
l'intitulé régulation
je mettrai pour ma part
euh toute une série de choses qui sont
ben un certain nombre de chapitre
d'action mais qui sont tous commandés
par l'idée que il n'y a aucune raison
que nos données et en particulier par
exemple notre propriété
intellectuelle soit
commandé du haut de l'édifice par
euh
la puissance économique monétaire
publicitaire d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises extérieur à l'Europe et
qui en quelque sorte
entre guillemets font travailler les
Européens par exemple les créateurs
européens exploitent la valeur qu'il
dégage mais non pas à leur profit mais
au profit de leurs entreprises
et ce que nous devons rechercher par la
régulation c'est que d'une manière ou
d'une autre s'institue un équilibre
entre ceux qui
incontestablement détiennent les savoir
les logiciels par exemple les les
produits les
terminaux et et la
puissance financière et ceux qui comme
nous les Européens n'ont pas encore
encore réussi à faire émerger je vais en
parler une industrie
importante et compétitive mais qui somme
d'une part en tant que client en tant
que consommateur et surtout en tant que
euh
déversant
dans le l'écosystème des milliards et
des milliards de données et en
particulier de contenu culturel
numérique en droit de dire que il n'y a
aucune raison que le système fonctionne
comme il fonctionne aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire de manière totalement
déséquilibrée et sans aucune
considération pour ce que en quelque
sorte nous Européens
apportons il y a d'abord des
considérations qui sont de caractère
juridique je vais pas épiloguer mais
chacun sait très bien que il y a un
débat actuel concernant les données
alors nous nous l'avons pris sous la
forme de la protection des donn donné
mais ce débat va au-delà de la
protection euh naturellement mais nous
nous l'avons pris sous forme de comment
est-ce qu'on modifier la directive de 95
sur la protection de la de la de la vie
privée mais je pense que il faut
considérer naturellement les les données
de manière plus plus plus large l'autre
élément juridique qui est extrêmement
important et qui demande à mon avis à
être réformé c'est naturellement le
droit de la concurrence le droit de la
concurrence aujourd'hui est appliqué
dans ce
domaine par dans l'Union européenne par
ceux qui mettent en œuvre le la
politique de concurrence en tant que
compétence exclusive c'est-à-dire la
commission de manière
et tout à fait tout à fait déséquilibré
c'est-à-dire en gros systématiquement au
profit de ces entreprises dont je
parlais tout à l'heure et au détriment
des acteurs européens et en particulier
des des ayant droit
euh des contenus culturels euh
numériques le deuxème aspect des choses
qui mérite d'être pris en considération
dans ce cette politique de régulation de
l'Internet au plan européen c'est
naturellement madame la Présidente n en
avz parlé c'est la la la fiscalité alors
là-dessus vous le savez tous il y a deux
euh grandes questions qui se pose est-ce
que l'Union européenne est capable
d'avoir une position sur la
fiscalité des sociétés
multinationales disons over the top qui
en tout cas toutes qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs dans le la production
physique ou qu'elle soit dans
l'industrie numérique optimisme optimise
la fiscalisation et l'imposition de leur
bénéfices de leur de leur revenu est-ce
que dans les négociations engagées
actuellement au sein de l'OCDE au sein
du G20 nous sommes capables de
distinguer une position européenne et de
la faire prévaloir et deuxièmement
est-ce que nous sommes décidés ou
capables de mettre en place
éventuellement et
notamment en attend
le temps très très long qui va s'écouler
avant que les conventions de l'OCDE ne
soi modifié un propre système européen
et qui pourrait être si jeose dire une
imposition pragmatique permettant
d'assurer un prélèvement équitable je
dirais sur ces sociétés lorsque sur leur
naturellement sur leur le les revenus
qu'elle
tirent des consommateurs de l'Union
européenne que ce soit par exemple des
revenus publicitaires ou ou ou ou des
droits ou euh des abonnements euh toutes
les les formules qui euh font que
euh ces entreprises euh aujourd'hui euh
euh ont une activité considérable
euh dans l'Union européenne et ne verse
au trésor européens que très peu
d'impôts mais euh comme vous savez tous
c'est exactement la même chose aussi
vis-à-vis du Trésor américain c'est bien
c'est même la raison pour laquelle pour
une fois le gouvernement américain et
l'Europe sont sur la même ligne dans la
négociation dans la renégociation des
conventions de CD mais je crois qu'il
serait très important que nous nous
mettions d'accord sur pour les 4 5 ans
intermédiaires sur notre propre système
et c'est là où peut-être on pourrait
tenter d'expérimenter euh des formules
comme celles qui ont été imaginées à
travers le rapport colincin et qui
consisterait à prélever sur les données
puisque c'est en tout cas quelque chose
qui nous appartient en tout cas jusqu'à
preuve de contraire ou plus exactement
euh il faudrait arriver à démontrer que
vraiment ça nous appartient et que ça
n'est pas ça n'a pas été totalement
capturé si je veux dire par le par le le
le le système
l'autre aspect de la fiscalité
naturellement c'est la fiscalité
indirecte sur laquelle le le chantier
qui a été ouvert c'est le chantier du de
la TVA à la fois la technique
d'imposition de la TVA et le taux de la
TVA sur les techniques d'imposition
c'està-dire sur l'harmonisation on est
aujourd'hui à la veille d'une réforme
très importante
c'est la mise en œuvre à partir de 1er
janvier 2015 de ce qu'on appelle le
régime définitif de la TVA et qui
permettra pour tous ces services
de d'appliquer le régime de TVA La TVA
du pays où le service est consommé et
non plus du pays où le service ù le
prestataire de service est installé ce
qui était le la la règle dans ce qu'on
appelait le le le régime
transitoire et dérogatoire de la TBA
vous savez tous je ne le précise pas
plus que pour le Luxembourg qui était le
grand bénéficiaire de ce régime
transitoire en fait il y a une
transition supplémentaire c'est que le
le le le le la nouvelle règle ne
s'appliquera pas complètement au 1er
janvier 2015 mais ne s'appliquera
complètement qu'au 1er janvier 2019
puisque pendant 4 ans c'est
progressivement que les recettes
actuellement tirées par le par le le
budget luxembourgeois de cette TVA
seront effectivement perçus par l'état
dans lequel le service est consommé 25
25 25 enfin plus exactement 75 50 25 et
puis é0
euh mais la mise en place de ce système
plus tout ce qui a été prévu dans le
règlement les guichets et tout ça c'est
c'est c'est une réforme
incontestablement euh positive et en
tout cas qui est très pertinente pour ce
qui concerne le numérique bien euh bien
entendu ça ne règle pas vous le savez
tous la question des taux donc
maintenant il s'agit de savoir l'état
dans lequel le service est consommé quel
taux peut-il appliquer et là on retrouve
donc la problématique sur lequel je vais
pas être très long parce que euh je m'en
suis déjà souvent expliqué vous la
connaissez parfaitement c'est est-ce que
pour favoriser l'émergence de service
numériquees européens et en particulier
de ceux qui distribuent des contenus
culturels
numérique je je j'emploie toujours
contenu culturel numérique parce que
c'est comme ça que c'est écrit dans tous
les règlements et et et en particulier
dans tous les textes en anglais mais
pour moi le véritable mot c'est œuvre de
l'esprit alors je peux pour le Sénat
français parler devre de
l'esprit mais si je m'applique à la
réglementation telle qu'elle est je je
parle de cultur content naturellement et
donc nous nous nous nous avons là
là-dessus
une un point dur enfin un point où le
laser s'est posé c'est celui du livre en
ligne mais en fait c'est une question
beaucoup plus générale est-ce que nous
sommes capables de revenir sur l'erreur
historique que nous avons faite en 2000
l'erreur historique que nous avons faite
en 2000 c'est que contrairement aux
Américains qui en 1998 ont décidé de
mettre en place des systèmes fiscaux
favorisant les services électroniques
nous avons décidé en 2000 dans le la
directive avec la directive sur le
commerce électronique d'imposer ses
services systématiquement au taux normal
c'est-à-dire au taux maximum de la TVA
et ça veut dire que en gros depuis 15
ans nous avons créé un V able faossé de
compétitivité entre les entreprises
américaines et les éventuell ou
existantes entreprises européennes et
Dieu sait si de nous n'avions pas besoin
de ça puisque par ailleurs ces
entreprise américaines bénéficient de
deux données qui situations qui elles
sont incontournables et à laquelle
auquel bienant on ne peut rien faire
c'est d'une part un marché de 350
millions euh de consommateur direct
immédiat et d'autre part et d'autre part
une industrie et un système de recherche
qui est celui qui en gros produit encore
à l'heure actuelle 80 à 90 % de tous les
contenus les logiciel les nouveaux
produits qui sont mis dans le le dans
dans dans le le le sur les plateformes
et dans le numérique il n'est que de
voir voilà bon euh bien bien entendu
tout ça s'appelle Samsung mais comme ça
vous savez très bien euh c'est même
l'objet d'un grand d'une grande bataille
entre Samsung et Apple
euh ça ne vient pas de Corée ù ça vient
très peu de de Corée et en tout cas ça
ne vient pas d'Europe et donc le le ce
cette question est une question qui ne
doit surtout pas être considérée comme
un nouveau petit bénéfice que nous
distribuerionssh aux écrivains ou aux
éditeurs ou aux libraires mais comme une
question centrale qui est la question de
est-ce que dans une politique je vais y
venir dans une stratégie européenne des
services numériques nous sommes capables
comme les américains l'ont fait et
continu à le faire d'ailleurs d'utiliser
l'arme
fiscale j'en viens naturellement au
trème sujet qui d'une certaine façon les
regroupe tous qui est la politique
industrielle qu'il endra de mener à
travers donc des régulations des mesures
fiscales et qui ferait
que pour résumer le marché
intérieur ne serait plus seulement un
espace de circulation mais deviendrait
aussi un espace de production et que
nous ne serions plus donc seulement une
Europe de consommateurs ouverte sans
frontières sans douanes sans rien du
tout avec nos 500 millions de
consommateurs offerts mais une Europe
dans laquelle on est capable de conduire
une stratégie industrielle c'est-à-dire
de faire en sorte qu'existent des
entreprises qui elles-mêmes fournissent
ces produits ou ces ou ces services et
il est clair que nous en avons tout à
fait la capacité car euh dans beaucoup
de domaines
euh dans l'industrie des logiciels euh
pour les les produits innovant pour les
objets connectés et bien entendu pour ce
qui concerne le domaine que je traite
plus particulièrement pour les œuvres de
l'Esprit nous sommes tout de même avec
une base et un socle absolument
considérable mais que nous avons été
jusqu'à maintenant incapable de
valoriser euh et que nous avons laissé
l'exemple de la musique est
naturellement le plus violent euh et le
plus symptommatique que nous avons
laissé valoriser par les entreprises
dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire les entreprises de service
euh et les services électronique euh
américain
euh cette
stratégie européenne des service
numérique il faut dire que il y a
quelques pays aujourd'hui qui commence
euh à la concevoir et il faut dire aussi
que la France est en tête de ces pays
euh nous avons été ceux qui avont
proposé euh la politique la plus
articulée je dirais la proposition la
plus articulé au Conseil européen du 25
octobre qui était en partie consacré à
ce sujet mais qui a été très largement
euh euh malheureusement détourné si je
veux dire par les questions euh très
urgentes de de l'immigration
euh mais dont il est sorti un certain
nombre de conclusions qui ne sont pas
qui ne sont pas nuls loin de là mais qui
sont naturellement très modestes euh le
le le pour les ministres de la Culture
la ministre de la culture française a
présenté à ses collègues ministre de la
Culture sous la présidence lituanienne
le 26 novembre un mémorandom pour une
stratégie européenne des services
numériques distribuant des contenus
culturels numérique et en particulier et
en particulier le livre et dans 2 jours
il va y avoir à à à chayot donc un forum
européen organisé par notre ministère de
la culture et au cours duquel il sera
question justement de trouver le moyen à
la fois avec les acteurs culturels les
gens des gouvernements des
agences comment essayer de créer un état
d'esprit une sorte d'alliance de Coal i
pour une politique européenne de la
culture dans l'environnement numérique
c'est-à-dire comme je le dis souvent
profitant de l'environnement numérique
c'est vrai que les l'attachement aux
identités le poids des histoires
et parlons en particulier de la France
le poids des politiques culturelles
nationales fait que la culture a a été
depuis l'origine soigneusement écarté de
la sphère communautaire et que dans les
traités aujourd'hui on peut conduire
quelques actions
d'appui et notamment quelques programmes
comme celui qui est mis en œuvre
actuellement et qui s'appelle Europe
créative et Don le le principal est le
programme média mais il n'y a pas de
compétences de l'Union européenne et
même pas de compétences
partagées pour ma part et et et et
dépassant si j'ose dire la question du
du du numérique je pense que le
numérique les services de distribution
numérique des œuvres de l'esprit étant
nécessairement transfrontière par
définition transfrontière ils nous
conduisent à élaborer une réponse qui
est une réponse européenne et même
peut-être sous certains aspects une
réponse communautaire euh et c'est pour
ça que pour ma part
et sans attendre naturellement qu'on
modifie un jour de nouveau les traités
et que par exemple on crée une
compétence partagée dans certains
domaines culturel entre la Commission et
les états entre l'Union européenne et
les États-membres je pense que on
pourrait essayer de conduire notamment
sous forme de coopération renforcée des
actions au
auquel seraiit associés 7 8 10 12
États-membres et de ce point de vue de
ce point de vue
euh
la le nouveau programme le programme du
nouveau gouvernement allemand enfin qui
n'est plus si nouveau le gouvernement du
mois de de décembre euh de la coalition
cdou SPD euh est très encourageant il
rejoint sur beaucoup de sujets no no nos
nos position mais comme toujours en
Allemagne le programme gouvernement est
une chose les prises de position et
l'action sont une autre et il y a encore
aujourd'hui sur beaucoup de ces sujets
et on aura peut-être l'occasion de le
vérifier au Forum de chayot dans dans
quelques jours il y a encore beaucoup en
Allemagne d'indétermination c'est-à-dire
que suivant les interlocuteurs que l'on
rencontre on na pas sur ce genre de
sujet tout à fait la même réponse et par
exemple vous connaissez très bien le
sujet sur les données la position
allemande par rapport au projet de
directive par rapport à la position
française est très est très différente
mais mais en même temps elle est très je
dirais indécise et donc le le le le le
partenariat avec l'Allemagne qui est
essentiel dans toutes ces affaires et
est difficile à à mettre en place et à
plus forte raison bien entendu une sorte
de coalition et l'alliance d'un certain
nombre d'états- membres pour faire une
coopération renforcée dans ce domaine
car c'est la dernière chose que je
dirais euh la réponse à la question que
la mission se pose c'est-à-dire une
stratégie européenne une une formule
européenne de de gouvernance et de
régulation se heurte d'abord à quelque
chose qui est une réalité que l'on vit
tous les jours c'est que les
États-membres sont divisés sur ces
sujets euh entre ceux qui n'ont pas
d'opinion et qui pensent que moins on en
parle M on porte et que il suffit de
consommer ce que euh les services
d'outremère nous donnent de meilleur et
au moindre pris ce qui ce qui au
contraire sont très clairement et
notamment dans une optique dans une
optique
antirégulatrice dans une optique très
libérale
sont favorables à ce que le dominant
domine et que le dominé soit dominé et
puis c'est tout et que c'est la loi du
c'est la loi du marché et puis une
troisème catégorie de pays
euh naturellement qui est mené par la
France avec à de plus ou moins grand
degrés des gouvernements des États qui
sont impliqués notamment pour ce qui est
des œuvres de l'esprit mais pas
seulement pour ce qui est des uvres de
l'esprit qui sont impliqués dans dans
l'idée que une
identité nationale et une identité
européenne qui est nécessaire dans ce
domaine puisque on est
transfrontière serait nécessaire alors
ça veut dire la France ça veut dire
l'Espagne ça veut dire l'Italie ça veut
dire la Belgique ça veut dire d'une
certaine façon la
Suède ça veut dire les Pays-Bas à
certains égard et puis et puis
l'Allemagne en tout cas si on met en
œuvre le contrat de le contrat de
coalition signé le 17 décembre voilà
euh madame la rapporteur ce que je
voulais vous dire peut-être à titre
d'introduction générale merci
beaucoup ben les longues introduction
déjà extrêmement précises j'aurais
quelques points de de détail s'agissant
des des des chantiers portant sur la TVA
euh euh vous savez que en France on a
voté le principe de l'alignement de la
TVA de la presse en ligne récemment sur
la presse papier la France commence à
être rejointe par d'autres pays en ce
qui concerne le numérique en tout cas
elle est elle est rejointe par le
Luxembourg évidemment on sait bien que
ça implique d'avoir l'adhésion de la la
Commission européenne du Parlement
européen et du Conseil de l'Union
européenne aujourd'hui quel état des
lieux dressez-vous est-ce que l'on en en
est quel est le degré d'avancement pour
relever ce ce
défi partagé et puis une autre question
vous avez évoqué le 1er janvier 2015
hein date à laquelle le taux de TVA du
pays où le service électronique est et
consommé s'appliquera aujourd'hui les
États européens précisément sont-ils
prêts à cette échéance parce que quand
nous avions auditionné sur ce sujet il y
a à peu près 2 ans on voyait bien nous
expliquer à quel point ça entraînit des
diff ulté administrative bureaucratique
et cetera quel é l'état des lieu même
chose sur ce sujet moi je je je
répondrai d'abord sur deè question j'ai
le sentiment que que la réponse est oui
c'est-à-dire que le règlement a quand
même
été mis en place il y a presque un an
hein
euh je crois que la plupart des pays
sont en état en tout cas moi les
informations que j'ai et et notamment
qui sont des informations qui viennent
de Bruxelles c'est plutôt que ça devrait
normalement se se se se passer comme
prévu au au 1ier au 1er janvier beaucoup
de progrès a été fait depuis que le
règlement d'application a été a été
actéin c'était je crois à l'automne
dernier ou l'été
dernier je me souviens plus exactement
sur le premier point
euh les l'état des lieux il est
euh suvant qu'on voit le vert à moitié
ville le vert à moitié plein préoccupant
ou ou ou inspirant bon c'est-à-dire que
premièrement la Commission on en est sûr
maintenant ne prendra pas position sur
ce sujet avant sa mort prochaine
l'actuelle commission bien
euh bon faute
de faute de vouloir affronter je dirais
le le le le le débat elle ne présentera
pas de proposition naturellement elle ne
présentera pas d'étude d'impact
elle dispose naturellement de tous les
éléments pour le faire mais le
commissaire en
charge appuyé d'ailleurs par le
président de la Commission a décidé que
ça n'était pas
politiquement opportun de le faire
maintenant donc c'est un sujet où la
prochaine commission et le prochain
Parlement vont avoir d'une certaine
façon non pas tout à faire car ça fait 3
ans que le le le dossier a été constitué
mais
euh vont avoir à se déterminer fin de
l'année ou début de l'autre qu'est-ce
que la Commission fait sur ce sur ce
sujet
euh c'est le deuxième point que je
voulais évoquer c'est que bien entendu
et contrairement à la situation qui
prévalait disons à la fin de 2010 ou au
début de 2011 au moment où O madame crus
a dans sa communication sur l'agenda
numérique en août 2010 pour la première
fois au niveau de Bruxelles posé la
question des taux divergents de de TBA
euh la Commission a travaillé sur ce
sujet elle a consulté elle a fait des
études et cetera bon je veux dire que le
débat a été ouvert ce qui est je dirais
le principal acquis de l'action que la
France et moi en particulier nous nous
nous avons mené sur ce sur ce sujet donc
on on a les éléments d'une position
politique mais pour des raisons
politiques la Commission ne veut pas le
ne veut pas le le le faire et aucune
pression de qui que ce soit et y compris
du Parlement européen n'y a fait quoi
que ce soit troisièmement troisièmement
dans l'état des lieux il faut que je
recite encore une fois le fait que
l'Allemagne est passée dans le camp de
ceux qui veulent le taux réduit elle est
passée dans ce camp je ne dis pas
qu'elle agit ce camp mais elle est
passée dans ce camp et donc pour peu que
la Commission fasse une proposition elle
se présentera à nos côtés en faveur du T
réduit mais elle ne prendra pas
d'initiative contrairement à ce que nous
nous avons
fait sur la presse en ligne c'est
justement une des questions qui se
pose sur le livre l'Allemagne ne prendra
pas d'initiative elle l'a dit je veux
dire les
responsables l'ont dit mais on peut se
poser effectivement la question madame
sur la la presse en ligne
car vous savez très bien quelle est la
situation de la presse en Allemagne la
presse est beaucoup plus puissante
encore en Allemagne qu'elle n'est
aujourd'hui et on peut imaginer on peut
imaginer que le gouvernement allemand et
le Bou SAAC bouge là-dessus je je ne le
crois pas car j'ai le sentiment que la
la position qui a été prise et de dire
politiquement nous sommes pour en
procédure nous ne ferons rien si ce
n'est à à partir d'une proposition de la
Commission mais on ne sait jamais sur la
presse en ligne euh le le sujet est donc
aujourd'hui
euh la la le même que celui du livre
simplement sauf que en ce qui concerne
le contentieux nous sommes à un stade
euh préalable il y a eu la procédure
pilote la procédure pilote est
maintenant terminée euh en réponse dans
la la procédure pailote la Commission a
dit à la France on n'est pas d'accord
avec vous et et on engage donc alors je
pense qu'on va avoir un jour ou l'autre
une mise en demeure est-ce que ça sera
avant les élections européennes est-ce
que ça sera après
euh je je je ne sais pas mais on on on
va sûrement engager un un contentieux
sur la presse en ligne étant entendu
dernière observation que les deux sujets
sont un peu différents alors d'abord il
y a une différence à l'encontre si je
veux dire du du du du de la presse en
ligne du taux réduit pour la presse en
ligne c'est que là on demande un taux
super réduit et qui est un taux qui
n'existe pas dans l'annexe 3 bon donc on
demande la création d'une catégorie bon
mais en revanche ce qui est favorable à
la presse en ligne c'est que pour la
presse en ligne la Commission ne peut
pas tenir le langage qu'elle tient
actuellement c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a
pas de substitution entre le marché du
physique et le marché du numérique vous
savez que sur le livre sa dernière
position c'est ça c'est de dire mais
qu'est-ce que vous me demandez de toute
façon c'est pas la même chose les les
les deux livres ah et il y a pas de on a
beau lu expliquer que aux États-Unis
barn nobles ferme le tiers de leur
librairie et que ça a probblement
quelque chose à voir avec le fait que 22
à 23 % du marché sont tenus euh du livre
est tenu par le par le numérique donc 80
% par par Kindle
euh rien n'y fait en revanche sur la
presse il est tellement manifeste et
tellement énorme que la presse est en
train de mourir de de la de la de la
distribution numérique gratuite bon euh
que il est quand même impossible que la
Commission tienne l'idée que ah mais il
y a pas à comparer les deux il y a pas à
à mettre à faire la neutralité fiscal
entre les deux puisque c'est pas le même
marché c'est pas le même produit bon
voilà et ça c'est un argument qui est
plutôt favorable à la presse par rapport
à la par rapport voilà mais madame la
rapporteur ce qui est clair c'est que
c'est un sujet en tout cas moi je
souhaiterais que ce soit un sujet pour
les futures échéances qui veut dire
d'abord pour les élections au Parlement
européen et ensuite une fois le
Parlement européen élu pour la
commission que le Parlement européen va
ratifier j'ai j'ai oublié je je voulais
juste dire dans dans le le les le topo
que j'ai fait naturellement j'ai oublié
une question mais c'est évident que ça
va s'en dire c'est que il y a dans le le
la la régulation en ce qui concerne le
droit il y a naturellement une question
essentielle c'est celle de la propriété
intellectuelle alors sur la propriété
intellectuelle en revanche l'actuelle
Commission va faire quelque chose
puisque vous le savez tous le
Commissaire Barnier présentera au plus
tard au mois de juin un livre blanc sur
la révision éventuelle de la directive
de 2001 voilà
euh à la suite notamment de la grande
consultation qui s'est terminé au mois
de
février là-dessus vous savez tous quels
sont les positions et notamment les
positions de la de la
France la plupart des États-membres
ont manifesté qu'il ne voulaaiit pas
qu'on rouvre la directive de 2001 mais
naturellement la Commission est soumis
soumise à de très fortes pressions d'une
part de l'industrie bien entendu de tout
poil et et d'autre part des
internautes et des activistes de de
l'Internet une question complémentaire
la neutralité du net on le voit
aujourd'hui fait l'objet d'un débat
important madame CROUS en a proposé une
version controversée dans dans son
projet de règlement continent connecté
quel est votre point de vue sur cette
neutralité du Net est-elle aussi selon
vous selon sa
définition propice à améliorer la la la
gouvernance de l'Internet alors c'est ça
que je je pense que sur la neutralité
c'est un des
sujets dont je crois qu'il faudrait
parler
euh dans
le l'accord international si je dire que
que j'appelle de mes vœux sur la
gouvernance de de de l'Internet parce
que
euh aujourd'hui la la neutralité
elle est définie
commefinie de fait comme la
faculté offerte
aux hébergeurs aux opérateurs aux
fournisseurs d'accès aux intermédiaires
techniques et cetera de
euh en quelque sorte
euh exercer leur libre choix de la
manière
dont fonctionne le système alors il y a
des il y a des partisans de la
neutralité pour lesquels neutralité
signifie possibilité d'intervenir c'est
certains opérateurs téléphoniques par
exemple pour qu' veulent réguler les
débits c'est un peu la conception de
Madame crus sur certains certains points
et puis il y en a d'autres pour lesquels
neutralité signifie au contraire totale
liberté c'est naturellement le point de
vue c'est naturellement le point de vue
aussi des activistes de de l'Internet
mais c'est un mot c'est un concept
totalement valise qui devrait justement
faire l'objet d'une définition
naturellement ma définition à moi elle
comporte mon point de vue elle comporte
la capacité d'intervenir et pas
seulement et pas seulement parce que il
faut empêcher les contenus
pédopornographique criminel ou autre je
je pense que la
le dans le cadre d'un accord
international sur la gouvernance de
l'Internet il faut simplement
tenir compte du fait que ce système
technique ne peut pas fonctionner comme
s'il ne comportait pas un certain nombre
de contraintes et toute la question est
de
savoir qui détient la capacité de mettre
en œuvre ou d'aménager ses contraintes
la question de la neutralité en fait
c'est la question du
pouvoir et ceux qui sont d'un côté les
activistes de l'Internet de l'autre côté
certaines compagnies tel que par exemple
Google sont partisans d'une neutralité
qui est une totale liberté parce que
c'est chacun de leur point de vue ce qui
les arrange en revanche en revanche il y
a des intermédiaires techniques ou des
opérateurs ou des des des opérateurs qui
eux naturellement gèent par exemple le
trafic et qui sont favorables d'une
manière ou d'un autre à ce qu'on ait la
possibilité de de de d'intervenir mais
toute la question mais toute la question
est de savoir quel est le règlement et
donc en l'occurrence l'accord
international qui le prévoit et quel est
celui qui si je peux prendre une image
un peu sommaire à la main sur le
robinet le le aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la
neutralité du Net c'est le le le le
comment dirais-je le concours c'est
c'est les Jeux olympiques de
l'hypocrisie c'est-à-dire que rien n'est
plus aujourd'hui un concept manipulé
chacun en fonction de ses intérêts que
la neutralité du Net voilà et si on veut
que on sorte de cette ambiguïé qui à mon
avis est néfaste pour tout le monde y
compris pour les internautes d'abord
euh il faut qu'on s'entende sur et au au
sur sur une définition il son au au au
fameux G8
qui avait eu lieu en en en 2008 à Cannes
c'est une question qui avait déjà
commencé à être
évoqué les Américains l'avaient en
quelque sorte écarté
mais je ne suis pas sûr que 6 ans après
euh la question n'est pas suffisamment
mûrie pour que justement dans les
conditions que je disais tout à l'heure
elle ne soit de nouveau euh évoqué ok
mais il ne faut pas non plus quand on
veut définir une certaine neutralité et
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
dans le cadre de cette neutralité des
mesures d'intervention
disons que on donne le sentiment que le
on on parle ù on légifère uniquement en
fonction de certains intérêts et c'est
probablement vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure la raison pour laquelle les
propositions de Nell crus sont
aujourd'hui controversé parce que elles
apparaissent comme trop unilatérales je
dirais d' d'une certaine façon d'où d'où
je crois la la formule d'essayer de se
mettre d'accord sur un cadre négocié
c'est c'est c'est
mais vous savez très bien
que comme je le disais dès le début
euh nous sommes dans un système
où la les accords diplomatiques sont
totalement dépassé puisque les
puissances en cause ne sont pas des
États ne sont pas des organisations
internationales ce sont de grandes
entreprises de de grands groupes donc il
faut arriver à mettre à la table euh un
un ensemble de de pouvoirs public
étatique et de pouvoir privé économique
euh pour essayer de leur faire décider
une
telle telle régulation une telle
réglementation ou euh c'est extrêmement
difficile car aujourd'hui ceux qui
détiennent le pouvoir privé bénéficient
incontestablement de la situation
actuelle et je dirais que d'une certaine
façon
on qu'est-ce qui pourrait les obliger et
qu'est-ce que qui pourrait les pousser à
venir à la table de négociation euh
toujours en 2008 quand il y avait eu
avant le G8 de Cann quand il y avait eu
les grandes réunions qui s'étaient
déroulé ici à Paris au au au tuerie euh
les les propos qui avaient été tenus à
l'époque par Monsieur Schmidt au nom de
de de Google étaient tout à fait clair à
à cet égard le bien de l'humanité
impliquait que il n'y ait rigoureusement
rigoureusement aucune entorse à la
neutralité c'est-à-dire aucun frein à
euh la puissance de l'entreprise dont il
est le
euh
CEO bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre de vous être rendu disponible
pour partager résultat de vos travaux et
de vos observations qui nous alimentent
très utilement pour notre mission
commune d'information le rapport tout
cas je pense que c'est très
important que que que ça soit pour les
que ça soit dans le débat européen c'est
ça qui me paraît voilà je suis pas sûr
que ça y sera pour en dehors du
procèsverbal je dirais que j'ai peur
qu'on parle beaucoup plus de l'ampedusa
que de la neutralité du Net voilà mais
nécessité fait loi voilà merci
beaucoup voilà depuis plusieurs semaines
les sénateurs de la mission commune
d'information sur le rôle et la place de
l'Union européenne dans la gouvernance
mondiale d'Internet multiplie les
auditions ils ont auditionné des
sociologues des chercheurs mais aussi
des entrepreneurs du monde d' Internet
et vous venez de le voir des anciens
ministres prochaine étape de cette
mission d'information la conférence de
Sao paullo qui va porter sur la
gouvernance mondiale d'Internet qui doit
être plus indépendante en clair moins
américaine également autre étape
importante la rencontre des sénateurs
avec leurs homologues allemands qui ont
également mis en place une mission sur
ce même sujet après l'affaire Snowden
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site
publsenat.fr Pr rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire 19h pour 24h
Sénat présenté par Delphine girérard
très bonne fin de journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaire